welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and I'm marina Mastro's Terminator
dark fate is the sixth Terminator film
or if you're only going by the ones that
James Cameron and Linda Hamilton had a
major creative influence on the third
Terminator filmed that matter yeah
nothing against the rise of the machines
or Terminator Salvation or terminator
genisys especially a Salvation since we
don't want Christian Bale to yell at us
give me a dancer what don't you get
about it sorry my fault my fault my
fault
but as diehard fans of the Terminator
franchise we can tell you that dark fate
is hands down the best Terminator since
t2 and B way this film updates a
terminator timeline post t2 is really
the best way to understand this whole
canonical history Eric and I are gonna
break down the full terminator timeline
and the ways Terminator dark faint
connected to and change that timeline
yeah and dark fade actually hits some
fun Easter egg references to t2 if
you're watching closely we're gonna
cover it off in this episode of it's
morning if you have not seen dark fate
yet or any of the other Terminator
movies and I guess you still care okay
quick summary of the timeline from the
first two terminators in the first film
set in 1984 the t800 arrives from the
Year 2029 to assassinate Sarah Connor
future mother of John Connor leader of
the human resistance in 2029 John Connor
was about to close in on the Machine
sent and the war so Skynet sent the
assassin in as a last-ditch effort Kyle
Reese also arrives from 2029 to protect
Sarah and they end up hooking up and she
becomes pregnant making Reese John's
father Reese dies and destroys the t800
Sarah escapes yeah time travel when the
Terminator films takes the form of
predestined loops so like what happens
has always happened it's confusing it's
why Avengers endgame said screw that
we're just gonna make cap olds and
everyone will cry and not care about the
weird logic except those of us who did
what
anyway t2 Judgment Day the next movie is
set in the year 1995 two years before
Skynet becomes self-aware and nukes the
planet Judgment Day 1997 Skynet 2029
sends a new Terminator the awesome
shape-shifting t1000 to kill John who's
now a punk kid with foster parents
Sarah Connor is imprisoned in a mental
hospital another t800 also comes back
but this time he was reprogrammed to
protect John they find miles Dyson a
Cyberdyne engineer who used the scavenge
of the t800 from the first film to build
what would later become all of Skynet
oops
t2 ends with them destroying that
technology destroying the t1000 and
destroying the reprogrammed t800 thumbs
up so sad so Judgment Day was erased or
was it yeah this is where terminator
dark fate picks up but we'll hold off on
that to briefly explain the other
timelines from the other movies that
unfortunately exist Terminator 3 arrives
of the machine to set in 2004 with
Skynet sending the T X this time another
reprogrammed t800 protects adult John
and his future wife Kate and it gets
them to a bunker in the mountains to
survive as Skynet actually takes over
and nukes the planet it happens that
brings us to the post-apocalyptic
Terminator Salvation oh good for you
and how was it it takes mix in the much
distant future of 2018 yeah
resistance leader John avoids a
complicated assassination attempt meets
Kyle Reese and scores a significant
victory against the machines now up
until this point the whole Terminator
history existed on one timeline that is
until Terminator Genisys switch
everything up to understand the timeline
logic of that movie we turn now to
YouTube this next video from neutron
star 15 marina I think we just
time-traveled what happened to Gabe he
was made obsolete by a more efficient
model Eric's definitely a human yikes
watch that video for details on
terminator genisys but here's the gist
the 1984 timeline as we know it was
completely reset so that Sarah Connor
had another friendly t800 racer from a
young age 1973 onward yeah Genesis plays
out like a shot-for-shot replayed the
first Terminator film combined with
element from t2 like a t-1000 the end of
jumping from 1984 ahead to 2017 when the
new Judgment Day was going to take place
due not to Skynet but to a worldwide OS
developed by miles Dyson son called
Genesis there are additional layers of
time-travel loops and logic that don't
totally make sense since it's more or
less shattered new Terminator timeline
which is why it's such a relief that
Terminator dark fate fixed it dark fate
basically picks up after t2 the movie
opens in 1988 with Sarah Connor and
teenage John at a bar in Mexico where
the drinking age is much lower and
suddenly a teen 800 walks up and kills
him right
in front of Sara this t800 was another
terminator that Skynet also sent back
without us knowing this makes sense
because why would Skynet only send one
assassin cover your bases now that his
mission is complete that t800 ends up
retiring in Texas he grows old he learns
to have a soul he becomes a drapery
salesman a devoted husband a stepfather
and his guilt
he continues to text Sarah Connor
coordinates of the terminators who would
continue to appear every two years from
the future so that she can kill him he
does so he says well John John joppa
with John Connor dead and Cyberdyne
destroyed the post-apocalyptic future
with Skynet has been erased instead an
AI called Legion has taken their place
and the leader of the human resistance
is Danny Ramos in a similar
time-traveling assassin pot begins again
yes now this time we're the present day
and the protector is Grace an Augmented
human super soldier from the year 2042
she is the tattoo of the coordinates to
that t eight hundreds home and a whole
group including its t800 and Sarah
Connor and grace and of helping Danny by
destroying their new legion terminator
in a hydroelectric turbine leaving only
Sarah Connor and Danny Ramos alive to
keep an eye on the young grace as
Judgment Day inevitably approaches
there's actually an awesome callback
with Danny watching young grace on a
playground through a fence just like
Sarah Connor in that Nick nightmare in
t2 I remember that this new updated
timeline closes the loop just like the
first two terminators did Danny becomes
the badass resistance leader because she
meets Sarah Connor and learns from her
this is just like how Sarah Connor
became about us because Kyle Reese came
back to protect her the act of time
trouble creates the history that led to
the future time travel in the first
place that's right predestined loops and
there are two clever ways that dark fate
cleans up the timeline while
acknowledging other hypothetical
timelines that might exist for movies we
might not want to remember look past and
future the idea that Skynet sent several
terminators to the Past
each a sad lonely robot walking the
earth to complete its task like mr.
meeseeks suggests an infinite number of
timelines that could play out infinite
numbers of ways and with the t800
stating that Judgment Day is inevitable
and the 70% range of certain deeds sets
the rules in this universe
in a way that a future AI takeover can
never be a race Judgment Day is always
upon us and these stories are just about
what we do is that inevitable dark
depressing future closes in on us a dark
future we just can't escape ok I'm back
I'm back
how does terminator dark fate rank among
the other Terminator films for you for
me it's a t2 t1 and then dark fate and
the others are just in a dark pit that I
do never like to look in follow us on
social media and subscribe to new
rockstars for explanations of the
constantly shifting timelines of every
cinematic universe thanks for watching
bye
[Music]